hallo ich meine liebe freuen und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen tag am
sonntag war ich weiß als woche sonntag
haben keinen kontakt das lag einfach
daran dass ich im urlaub war oder ist
danach keine zeit mehr hatte und ich
wollte dass da nicht alles so bleibt
geschnitten alles irgendwie als raw
datei hochladen deswegen kommt das jetzt
so ein bisschen schöner zusammengestellt
was kommt denn ja es kommt etwas von
meinem urlaub und zwar war ich vier tage
an der nord zu überlisten mit einem
freund namens chris allerdings haben wir
uns wir haben zwar vorgenommen richtig
viel zu film und daraus einen richtig
geilen road trip zu machen
in der umsetzung haben wir dann
allerdings nur die hinfahrt und die
rückfahrt gefilmt weil wir als wir dort
waren immer vergessen in die kamera
mitzunehmen und ehrlich gesagt war
unsere speicherkarte dann auch irgendwie
voll und wir hatten keine pop mit und
wasser drauf zu packen da ist möglich
deswegen seht ihr nur die hinfahrt und
die rückfahrt in diesem video und ich
würde sagen ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal
ein paar szenen von der helfer freunde
oder schreiben bevor dresscode redet ich
lass das mal ganz kurz zusammen was
heute passiert ist willkommen zu den
kontakt wahrscheinlich heute am sonntag
wir fahren ich wohl den apfel bielefeld
wir fahren weiter landstraße alles voll
und ganz wichtig nach einer dort ist
nach hause gebracht
sie hatte schon wenig zeit kein
schlüssel damals ein kumpel gefahren
schon so gut wie dahin solle den
vergeben hätten wir gerade einfach mit
weihnachten fand ich die ganze zeit
hochgefahren und wir kommen zwei minuten
an bevor unser flieger gehen
das für die angriffe mit dieser kamera
so schreibt jetzt stehen wir auf jeden
fall grad im stau
langeweile und punkte zu machen
ich weiß ich das ganze später zusammen
steinebach ein schickes woraufhin weil
immer so richtig loslegen will noch
schnell selbst schon gesehen die
hinfahrt war ich total chaotisch also
wir sind quasi hingefahren und auf der
hälfte des weges wir zurückgefahren
wieder nach hause weil ich realisiert
habe dass ich meine jacke vergessen habe
weil ich meine jacke geschnappt wieder
ins auto mit christ bin nach wieder an
zunutze gefahren zum flughafen und dann
waren wir wirklich am flughafen zwei
minuten bevor unser flug ging und das
hat alles noch gut geklappt und deswegen
was richtig geil
nur wir haben dann quasi auf der insel
ist so viel gefilmt als wären den urlaub
fahren ich würde allerdings mehrmals
erkannt von ich kann mich wird vier mal
erkannt
alle leute waren mega korrekt bis auf
eine gruppe von leuten die haben mich
die ganze zeit über durch die ganze
innenstadt verfolgt bis zum strand und
habe mich dann ist angesprochen waren
zwar dann auch mega korrekt zu mir aber
dass man quasi nicht von anfang an sagt
hey luca oder irgendwie so sondern
einfach eine ganze zeit verfolgt das war
so ein bisschen da die so ein bisschen
an dem fall sind wir dann am dienstag
wieder gefahren dann habe ich so ein
paar sachen im flugzeug noch gefilmt und
dann auch auf der rückfahrt und dass sie
jetzt das
in der w
mainz
wir sind jetzt hier sind jetzt gerade
mit fliege angekommen und ich habe ihm
gesagt er soll keine 1,5 liter flasche
noch einpacken und er macht einfach
unschön ist genau mein brötchen das ist
jetzt eine richtige missgeburt dieses
brötchen du arschloch europa mit luca
allen ist jetzt quasi was bin ich
einfach über die rückwand aber nicht
weil der urlaub da deswegen hab ich noch
ein paar bilder die ich euch jetzt eine
blende und ich will das ganze video auch
nicht immer wieder länger als irgendwie
zehn minuten machen oder so sondern dass
wir uns ein bisschen kürzer halten
ich habe einfach nicht mehr filmen
können und auch nicht wollen würde wenn
ich konnte weil ich bin eine person die
sehr gerne die sachen die sie sieht
einfach erlebt und nicht so gerne
festhält indem man das andere leute
machen zehn million fotos ich laufe
lieber durch eine stadt die ich mag und
schauen wir alles an und denken sowohl
gallen und macht es nicht so gerne
später bereuten ihr euch das immer dass
ich nicht so viel gefilmt dafür euch
jetzt auch aber in dem moment den ich
mal von der ich hab kein bock fotos
mache ich das einfach erleben
vielleicht kennt ihr das meine kamera
wackelt weil ich gerade auf meinem bett
sitzen wenn ich mal hier ein bisschen
zurück um ihr seht ihr immer noch nicht
dass ich auf dem bett sitzt gar keinen
sinn da kann irgendwann wird das best
sehen will ich zurück bin einfach nur
blöd jedenfalls war das ganze relativ
unspektakulär der ganze urlaub an sich
war megageil war richtig gutes wetter
richtig gerne sachen haben wir gemacht
immer abends am strand und so war
richtig toll allerdings nicht informiert
gefilmt dementsprechen tut mir das leid
es tut mir auch sehr leid dass darüber
letzten kontakt gehandelt hat es war
wirklich nur einfach noch ein bisschen
material live witziges worüber ich reden
wollte gerade mein handy geklingelt aber
das ist halt egal ich glaube das hat man
eh nicht der nächste konter allerdings
sind wieder mal so ein bisschen so sein
dass ich euch ab und zu mal mitnehmen
wenn ich irgendwo rum fahre wenn ich
irgendwo chile dass dieser kontakt quasi
wieder zu dem ursprung zurück kommen
dass ich quasi jeden tag was film in der
woche und das am sonntag alles zusammen
schneidet dann quasi meine wochen
zusammenfassung für euch und nächste
woche wird was richtig gutes kommen zwar
willig zu einer rennstrecke
und da werde ich versuchen für euch auch
so ein paar sachen zu filmen also freut
sich darauf wenn sie trotzdem gefallen
hat sein mag ich und da will ich sagen
euch einen wunderschönen abend heute am
sonntag
und ich gucke jetzt erstmal wm weiter